what's happening there reject nation
just greg today here because everyone i
know has seen this movie john has seen
it multiple times and i've gotten a lot
of flack for never having seen it and
that is the movie forrest gump starring
thomas the hanks yup the time has come
for this long epic film i hope i hope i
like it after after what everyone's
always raved about but uh guys as usual
thank you to the super sexy rejects for
showing your support to us over the
years full-length watch alongs for
forrest gump will be over at our patreon
page along with a bunch of other things
we cover as well many of those shows
have reaction highlights included as
well but if you can't do that please
leave a like that would be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
for when our next movie reaction is up
got a lot of things in the pipeline
actually so excited for what we have in
store for 2022 and then boys at prepper
thank you for helping me edit down these
highlights couldn't do it without you
let's get into it
alan silvestri marvel zone composer alan
silvestri
[Music]
this feather flying through
multiple stories of lives and i'm trying
to pick up thematically what it means
[Music]
oh you know it's funny i had a plaid
shirt looks like that i almost wore that
one
see
my name's forged forrest gump do you
want a chocolate
never take candy from a stranger my mom
always said
life was like a box of chocolates you
never know what you're gonna get
those must be comfortable shoes my feet
hurt
well i'm always saying there's an awful
lot you could tell by the person buy
those shoes
very true that's why we're ferragamo
mama said they'd take me anywhere
you can open your eyes now let's take a
little walk around
oh
now when i was a baby mama named me
after the great civil war hero general
nathan bedford for us he started up this
club called the ku klux klan oh my god
and act like a bunch of ghosts or spooks
or something
what
and anyway
that's how i got my name oh
god
he's gonna have to go to special school
he's not going to some special school to
learn how to retread ties
we're talking about five little points
here is that mr gump
yeah this is gone
oh god
oh your mama sure does care about your
schooling son
you don't say much do you
eh
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
one time a young man was staying with us
and he had him a git talk case oh here
we go
[Music]
i was just showing him a thing or two on
the guitar here
that's supposed to be
actual elvis it sounded good
oh my god he invented elvis's dance
moves this one night me and mama was out
shopping and we walked right by a bench
he's running to an appliance store guess
what
and here i was thinking that all of us
it was appropriate black culture taking
advantage of little kids are you coming
along
thomas enough to be taking rise from
strangers
this is a busted school
i'm forest for skunk i'm dorothy harris
well now we ain't strangers anymore what
a good heart kid
i do remember the first time i heard the
sweetest voice in the wide world
you can sit here if you won't
i had never seen anything so beautiful
in my life
i just sat next to her on that bus and
had a conversation all the way to school
like a question mark these are going to
make me next to mommy
no one ever talked to me or asked me
questions
are you stupid or something
stupid as a stupid noise i've heard that
she helped me learn how to read
and i showed her how to swing
she's not doing anything you're doing
man just run away for us
run
hear some of the things you've
like heard in passing before
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh damn
forest unleashed the forest awakens
[Music]
that's some touching ass [ __ ] dude
that day on
if i was going somewhere
i was running
[Laughter]
that's so cool she lived in a house that
was that was alabama her mama had gone
up to heaven when she was five and her
daddy was some kind of a farmer he was a
very loving man he was always kissing
and touching her and her sisters
oh my god are they implying what i think
they're implying did you hear me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
who in the hell is that and they as far
as gun coach
and can you believe it
i got to go to college too
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no way
[Applause]
gosh really makes you want to exercise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
way to go for us
[Music]
stop stop running man president kennedy
ordered the secretary of defense then to
use military force hereby videotape is
the encounter by general graham
commander of the national guard and
governor wallace
because this movie's more mature than i
expected it's been
[Laughter]
ma'am you dropped your butt man so you
wouldn't have gum
no that couldn't be
sure as hell was that
when wallace got shot
i was in college it was co-ed cause
jenny went to a college i couldn't go to
but i'd go and visit her every chance i
got
oh you got to be [ __ ] me jenny
[Music]
oh
brought you some chocolate
i'm sorry
i'll go back to my college now
forest
oh
for a guy
have you ever been with a girlfriend i
sit next to them in my home economics
class all the time
damn jetty you've been so far with him
since you were like little
little kids man
[Applause]
they put you in this little room with
just about anything you'd want to eat a
drink
and since number one i wasn't hungry the
thirsty and number two they was free
i must have drank me about 15 dr pebbles
my god congratulations how does it feel
to be an all-american very good sir
congratulations how do you feel
i got a pig
i believe he said he had to go pee
that's pretty good technology man after
only five years of playing football i
got a college degree
congratulations son
mama was so proud
first i'm so proud of you dude she's
aged like 40 years hello i'm forrest
forrest gump how about you give the
husky [ __ ] who you are boss ball it's
your [ __ ] ass on the bus you're in
the army now
saints titan
tight oh what's up god damn meet this
guy
my name's forrest gump
people call me for skunk
so bubba was from biola battery alabama
and his mama cooked shrimp
bubba i'm going into the shrimp and
business for myself
after i get out the army
okay
your sole purpose in this army to do
whatever you tell my drill sergeant god
damn it trump
your goddamn genius that's the most
outstanding answer i've ever heard
your nets along the bottom
on a good day you can catch over 100
pounds of shrimp
everything goes all right bubba gum
shrimp is pineapple shrimp
lemon shrimp coconut shrimp
pepper shrimp shrimp soup shrimp stew
shrimp salad
he found the perfect friend to listen to
him let's give a big round of applause
to the luscious bobby dylan
[Music]
from
hollywood california huh
her dream had come true she sleeps in
the sand she was a folk singer
go punch that man you can't keep doing
this all the time
i can't help it
i love you oh
we prayed for god to turn me into a bird
so i could fly far far away
you think i could fly off this bridge
damn jetty's life is so goddamn
depressing
they sending me
to vietnam
this is whole other country
just if you're ever in trouble don't try
to be brave you just run okay just run
away
okay
and just like that
she was gone
this poor guy
so simple-minded
where you boys from in the world alabama
you twin
no we are not relations
try and keep your feet dry when we're
out humping i want you boys remember to
change your socks whenever we stop
me calling the leader grunts feet right
off his legs
sergeant sims
god damn it where is that sling rope i
told you that kind of miscarries denise
man you're cool actor trying not to do
anything stupid
like getting yourself killed
i sure hope i don't let him down
he seems like he's on some sort of
spectrum right doesn't quite strike me
as directly autism could just be
simple-minded
hearted and we were always looking for
this guy named charlie
one day it started raining and it didn't
quit for four months wow
i even wrote jenny and told her all
about it
told her how i thought about her always
and how i was looking forward to getting
a letter from her just as soon as she
had the
time damn what a different path
just like that
somebody turned off the rain and the sun
come out
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa
oh my god i ran so far so fast
pretty soon i was all by myself which
was a bad thing
bubba was my best good friend i had to
make sure he was okay
oh god no just leave me here get
god i up leave me here god damn it then
it felt like something just jumped up
and bitten
[Music]
i got an airstrike inbound right now
they're gonna need the whole area
don't you stay here goddammit that's an
order i gotta fight bubba
i will never be as good of a person as
this guy
oh god
okay forest
i'm okay
oh
no
that's his best friend
really good effects
i would rather put that together what
just happened
you got shot
i want to go home
bubba was my best good friend oh
it was a bullet wasn't it
it jumped up and [ __ ] they said it was
a million-dollar wound but
the army must keep that money because i
still ain't seen a nickel at million
dollars
it's time for your bath lieutenant
oh [ __ ]
come on i'm forrest gump
tuttle
[Music]
oh
man
i thought this was a feel-good movie
what did i walk into
now the secret to this game is
no matter what happens
never take your eye off the ball
so i started playing it all the time
[Applause]
i played ping-pong even when i didn't
have anyone to play ping-pong with
ping-pong is so fun i gotta get a
ping-pong table
the hospital's people said it made me
look like a duck in water whatever that
means
cool
you cheated me
i had a destiny i was supposed to die in
the field with honor
that was my destiny and you
cheated me out of it
god damn it
do you understand what i'm saying gump
so heart rate
president johnson awarded four medals of
honor to men from each of the armed
owes you a debt of gratitude son
i understand you were wounded
where were you hit
in the butt talks uh
oh that must be a sigh
i'd kind of like to see that
[Music]
streets was awful crowded with people
looking at all the statues and monuments
and some of them people were loud and
cushy okay follow me
everywhere i went i had to stand in line
oh my god is forrest gump going to do
lsd yeah yeah so psychedelics first
there was this man giving a little talk
and for some reason he was wearing an
american flag for a show
his name was charlie manson
well there's only one thing i could say
about
the war in vietnam
[Music]
[Music]
she keeps talking
that's it
that's all i have to say
about that
that's the right on man
you said it all
[Music]
she showed me around
and even introduced me to some of her
new friends
shut that blonde man and get your white
ass away from that window don't you know
we in a war here
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the middle of your black panther
party
[Laughter]
we walked around all night jenny and me
just talking
she told me about all the traveling she
done
and how she discovered ways to expand
her mind
we have very different lives you know
i want you
to have this
oh
oh
i can't tell if she views him as a big
brother or
you know more fluctuates so i was in the
special services
traveling around the country cheering up
all them wounded veterans and showing
how to play ping pong
the army decided that i should be on the
all-america ping-pong team when i got
home
i was a national celebrity
famous or even in captain kangaroo
uh here he is forrest gump right here
i'd watch a whole movie about him
playing ping-pong man people hardly got
nothing at all
no possessions
they never go to church
no religion too
ah
hard to imagine
well it's easy if you try dick
some years later
lieutenant dyn said he was living in a
hotel and because he didn't have no legs
he spent most of his time exercising his
arms
i stayed with lieutenant dane and
celebrated the holidays
gary sinise is so good in this movie
have you found jesus yet no
i didn't know i was supposed to be
looking for
him before you go
why don't you get your ass down in the
corner and get us another bottle of red
yes sir your neighbor like has
alcoholism gary sinises resentment in
their conflict is so good but in the
middle of all that fun i began to think
about jenny
wondering how she was spending her new
year's night out in california
[Music]
coming sharon stone from casino poor
woman just abused her whole life man
daddy's your friend's stupid story don't
call him stupid hey don't you punch him
yeah shut up don't you ever call him
stupid
oh no
there's some great effects
come on forest start up the shrimp
business give them a purpose a few
months later they invited me and the
ping pong team to visit the white house
so i went
again
[Laughter]
well where are you staying
it's called the hotel ebot oh no no no i
know of a much nicer hotel it's brand
new very modern i'll have my people take
care of it for you
send a maintenance man over to that
office across the way
the lights are off and they must be
looking for a fuse box or something
because in flashlights they're keeping
me awake
thank you
good night
oh my god
therefore
i shall resign the presidency effective
at noon tomorrow
your career will be ruined or you'll die
around forrest gump i have your
discharge papers
service is up son discharge
you have an age a day since he
went off to join the army i took mom out
to a real fancy dinner and i bought a
bus ticket and three dr peppers
tell me something
are you stupid or something
it is super does i love it
putting all that on gas
ropes and new nets the brand new shrimp
and boat
he did it for us
go hire lieutenant dan now i haven't
heard from jimmy in a long while
but i thought about her a lot
and i hoped that whatever she was doing
made her happy
damn she's gonna od isn't she
[Music]
oh [ __ ] no way
[Music]
wow i thought she was really gonna do it
showed up
[Music]
what are you doing here
well
thought i'd try out my sea legs
well you ain't got no legs lieutenant
well well captain forrest gump i had to
see this for myself
i told you if
you were ever a shrimp boat captain that
i'd be your first mate well here i am
yeah yeah but don't you be thinking that
i'm gonna be calling you sir
no sir
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
still no shrimp lieutenant day okay so i
was wrong
well how are we gonna find them
well maybe you should just pray for
shrimp
[Laughter]
he's like drax
hurricane carmen came through here
yesterday destroying nearly everything
in its path wow
[Music]
only one shrimping boat actually
survived the storm wow
after that shrimping was easy since
people still needed them shrimps for
shrimp cocktails and barbecues and all
we were the only boat left standing
bubba got shrimp's what they got bubba
gup
forest
never thanked you for saving my life
[Laughter]
forrest had a phone
we sure call you straightened out didn't
we boy
i forgot that was the same doctor
i didn't know it
but i was destined to be your mama
i did the best i could
you did good yeah great
so i i never went back to work for
lieutenant dan he got me invested in
some kind of
fruit company
and so then i got a call from him saying
we don't have to worry about money no
more and i said
that's good
[Laughter]
fruit company i gave baba's mama bubba
shea
she didn't have to work nobody's
catching them all awesome
and then
she was there all right i'm ready to
marry you now
jenny came back and stayed with me
i did all the talking
jenny most at times
was real quiet
nightmare home
how can you
do this
god
i had no idea that her story would be so
goddamn heartbreaking him is this one
constant good thing in her life
and she even showed me how to
dance then he became a worldwide famous
dancer
and well
we was like family jenny and me
i hope she does not leave
i swear to god man
will you marry me
i'd make a good husband jenny
you don't want to marry me
why don't you love me jenny
oh man
she take it off so i ran to the end of
the road
and when i got there
i thought maybe i'd run to the end of
town president carter suffering from
heat exhaustion fell into the arms when
i got there
i thought maybe i just run across
greenbelt county this is the best nike
commercial for no particular reason i
just kept on going
[Music]
i ran clear the ocean
santa monica i figured since i've gone
this far
i might as well just turn back
keep right on going
you're gonna need some glucosamine for
those knees man so
you just ran
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a nice
sense of adventure to this makes you
want to explore a little bit a man named
a gardener from greenville alabama
stopping only to sleep has been running
across america
they just couldn't believe that somebody
would do all that running for no
particular reason why are you doing this
i just felt like running
i mean it was like an alarm went off in
my head you know i said here's a guy
that's got his act together here's
somebody who's got it all figured out
here's somebody who has the answer
i followed you anywhere mr gum
[Laughter]
i had run for three years
two months
14 days and 16 hours
i'm pretty tired
i think i'll go home now
oh man shh could have been at something
so i went home to alabama
oh
poor people putting their faith in
one day i had a blue clear sky i got a
letter from jenny wondering if i could
come down to savannah and
see her and that's what i'm doing here
what's going on
henry street is just five or six blocks
down that way
everything works out for you
whoa it's weird seeing him off the bench
i want to apologize for anything that i
ever did to you because
i was messed up
this is my very good friend mr gump here
can you say hi to him hello mr god it's
that haley joel hussman his name's
forrest
like me i named him after his daddy
he got a daddy named forrest too
you're a daddy forrest
wow
there's nothing you need to do okay you
didn't do anything wrong it's the most
beautiful thing i've ever seen
[Laughter]
is he's smart
he's very smart
he's one of the smartest in his class
looking so sad
i have some kind of virus
and the doctors don't they don't know
what it is and there isn't anything they
can do about it would you marry me first
okay
oh
oh what
no way
you got new legs titanium alloy
it's what they use on the space shuttle
magic legs
[Laughter]
oh no
hey
are you scared in vietnam sometimes it
would stop raining long enough for the
stars to come out
that was
million sparkles on the water
beauty and the struggle
you died on a saturday morning
mama
always said
dying
it was a part of life
yeah
and every night we read a book she's so
smart jeffy you'd be so proud of him
i am
oh
my god damn each have a
destiny or if
we're all just floating around
accidental like on a breeze maybe both
is happening at the same time
yeah
i miss you jenny
if there's anything you need
that's a really heartbreaking i know
this i'm going to share that for
so-and-so because
brandon used to read it to you
my favorite book
feather fell out
good movie man
i know buddy
been in here a while
let's just chat about it all right here
we are forest gump gump finally talking
about forrest gump it's weird
i kind of had this identity as the guy
who had never seen forrest gump in
circles i always loved the expression
but you've never seen forrest gump
now here we are
it's funny watching this because
um i would constantly hear
the the rhetoric would change over time
about this movie
in random circles i would run into
i'm sure if i looked up an article
online it would
tell me all the reasons why forrest gump
is a problematic movie now because i
would hear that
and not knowing what the movie was
had no real basis other than just that
word problematic i didn't know why
today there would be things about that
are considered problematic
there are things i can venture to guess
why some might consider it
problematic
um
but that's not my job to sit here and
try to dissect it i'm not here to do
some video essay about why for scope is
problematic you know like there are some
things i might say in passing as i'm
talking about it
uh but all i have to do is just tell you
how what my feelings on the movie are
and i think it wears its sentimental
heart on its
shoulders very well
like it's such a fantasy movie
that whatever might be considered
problematic because
it's a story about i i don't know if
this if if he's
supposed to be it seems the movie
strikes me as
like he he's on the spectrum of some
sort so it doesn't ever outright declare
he is doesn't ever say he has like
asperger's or autism or something like i
don't i don't know
if the movie was actually doing that
after a while i'm like he's probably
just a simple-minded guy
you know with a great big heart
and
to me the movie was more about
that
because he's kind of coasting through
life through most of this
with
just naturally accumulating some of the
greatest world experiences with such
simplicity
that i like that i really appreciate
that quality of it so much because he's
surrounded by terrible things like he
give us the freaking vietnam war for
crying out loud uh the woman he loves
for verse for eternity
is is down such a temperatureless path
and while he might be
blind to so many things he's surrounded
by racism for crying out loud and so
if i were to guess
really quick if i were to guess why
people might consider this problematic
today
i'd i'd have to say it's because of the
political
angles that people might draw from it
because
this movie while
covering political american history
events
it doesn't really seem to be about
politics to me
it's sort of the backdrop of the
experiences but it's more of a
commentary on
humanity
yeah i probably i i i'd probably just go
that way like you know he's
picks up the book at the college for
for the black student who is getting
accepted into the into the school um
even when the black panther person's
talking to him it's kind of played like
a joke
and he's not really
doesn't really seem to be taking it in
so a lot of like the
the messages about racism that you could
probably do to make this more of a
powerful impact to really have something
to say the movie doesn't really seem too
interested in that it seems more
interested in just exploring the
the simplicity of life
that you can go about it in a way
that doesn't have to be as
complex and still lead something great
and to be appreciative of
what's in front of you and in the
present moment as well
like there's a lot of qualities to this
forrest gump character who
it's interesting like i i wonder if this
role had come out today if this would
have gotten tom hanks the oscar because
it's a really it's in a lot of ways it's
it's not i wouldn't call it one note
that would be very unfair to call the
character one note um he's just so
simple and then his emotions seem to
kind of hover between like happy sad
and
misunderstanding like a misreading of a
situation you know he takes everything
so literally
and
and i like that about him i really like
that because
while it's at times it might read as
like a really simple performance it
works so well for
the movie
because he's always just about doing
what he feels is the good thing we're
doing the right thing or doing his duty
you know just going through
life and and following his feelings and
following what he just
believes in the moment he has to do
despite how other people might try to
read it as something more at times you
know it might just be just because
and
as simplistic as that is there's
something about that i find
really fascinating to watch and also i
don't know i guess i don't really get
offended by any of the things that might
be lacking in something that could be a
true heavy like social political
commentary
it's in such a fantasy world like this
this movie i didn't know that going in
like it's such a
fantastical world
but it but imbued in real life you know
and like using historical events which i
thought was
a really nice nuanced touch to have
this jenny character
that threw me for a loop you know at the
beginning they imply
the sexual abuse from her father
and
how
having had having not overcome that
it has created a ripple effect
of
lack of vulnerability attachment issues
escapism like she just goes through this
cycle of abuse
for the rest of her life and never truly
coming in terms with it it doesn't seem
until she like has a kid so
i don't know if there's something
problem i'm gonna do caught up in it
it's just that was the other voice that
was in my head the whole time of why do
people think this movie is problematic
now because i thought the movie was
actually really sweet
and and it was so much about
love you know like i i thought robin
wright's performance was really good
and i really liked um
the
performance by gary sinise i thought was
actually my personal favorite in here i
loved his
whole character arc you meet him at the
moment
where it's like prime lieutenant dan you
know this is what he does he's part of
the jungle he knows war and he is ready
to die
honor the legacy of his ancestry of
everyone who died in the great american
war before him
and he felt like he was destined for
that
and even though forrest saves his life
he resents him for that action because
he doesn't know how to appreciate his
own life but
by being closer to forest and being
friends with him
and watching his life change he finds
plenty to be grateful for and then finds
love
i think it's [ __ ] like that that what
the movie is really about is
yes there's a lot about persistence
and even though he's often met with very
little struggle
sometimes we get in our own ways i think
that's an interesting commentary about
humanity is sometimes we complicate
things ourselves so much this is a
fantasy world okay and it's not the real
world but in life i'm saying that
sometimes we do
get in our own heads way too much we
oftentimes our biggest obstacle is just
within it's just ourselves and we have
to overcome that
and as someone who does not
register obstacles the way how other
people do
he's able to kind of lead more of the
life that
other people often desire because he's
surrounded by people who are struggling
constantly you know like the moms and
dad it has to sleep with the principal
to get him into school gary sinise jenny
obviously very
very tough
lives everywhere he goes it seems like
everyone's kind of having like a tougher
life than
he is and i think that's part of the
inspiration of this character is you
know i'm trying to go back to what it
must have been like to watch him for the
first time of
i wish we more of us could be that way
everyone's like always searching for
such a purpose you know where him he
he looks for adventure
without really thinking like that he's
just kind of going with the feeling like
when he decides to go run across the
world for three plus years
and
how he creates this following of
everyone who's trying to
add more meaning to
what he's doing when he's like no i just
i just wanted to
whenever when a lot of times we try to
make things more profound than what they
really are
and maybe there is more to dissect of
why forrest gump the character made that
choice that he might he might not even
be aware of
what i thought was really cool about the
way that was handled was like every one
of the journalists were
just like what are you doing this for
they're all listing a bunch of different
political agendas that forest could be
doing this run for that it's symbolic
for something deeper and
it never was
for him it was like a
an instinct i can imagine there's an
emotional route to it like he's going
through pain and this is his way of
working it off in some ways this is you
know jenny escapes maybe this was his
way of escaping
uh but
it's not to try to he's surrounded by
messages all the time and political
agendas all the time
throughout his life as as most of us are
and yet it was always about finding the
simple way through it all you know
something that oftentimes is like very
black and white thinking
friends are in danger in vietnam i gotta
go save them despite what everyone else
is saying i should do
run don't run
very very simple way of thinking and i
keep using the world the word simple
because
that's
i guess i was
expecting to walk into a movie that was
going to be like
so heavy on messages and so deep
and in a lot of ways it's deep in a way
that is not as complicated or or as
complex as i expected it to be
and i appreciate that about the journey
because it's like
it touches on subjects and terror like
especially with the jenny character like
it touches on so much and then there's
like the war violence that is so much
more
mature than i expected it to be
because he is like a child in a in a
grown man's body
going through life and surrounded by
adult situations and everything seems
kind of
foreign to him
i guess i'd consider it problematic if
the movie outright declares like he's an
autistic guy because i think the way
movies often portray autistic characters
is not always
uh
good
like normally when the characters
normally autistic characters are
portrayed in movies it's it's like
they're they're math geniuses or some
[ __ ] or like they solve like the alien
rubik's cube of life or some [ __ ]
and uh
yeah they're always like you're secretly
a genius yes if it's a power to use it
and uh i'm curious because i thought it
was based on a book and i don't know if
the book would declare that he directly
is
um but they don't really lean into that
too much like he was still able to just
see him as a as a guy who just views who
has
just a sim keep using the word simple
like i'm beating that word to death here
he just has a really easy way of looking
at life
and
doesn't get in his own way too often he
just
goes about it he is like a soldier
running through life and as so i think
like him going to war is very apt for
the character
because
as a soldier through life he's just
following what life is telling him to go
follow and i think that is so cool
because most of us don't
do that and i think a lot of us
find success in in many areas of our
life when we're least thinking about the
end result of things you're just
focused on the moment doing what you
have to do
and then
naturally you might accumulate some
things that eventually lead to success
or fact you just don't know most of the
time and
i really like it i don't know i thought
it was a really sweet film i thought it
was something that
was um
very moving very emotional
and had a great heart
and i just i thought the uh well the
song was from the freaking early 90s so
while some of the visual effects are a
little bit wonky i think for the most
part they hold up pretty well like they
would be so much better today they would
do like full-on defects or you just get
some cgi actor in there really really
match the words of the mouth but
as it stands i still think the visual
effects are i think the visual effects
on like jerry sinise who obviously has
his legs in real life like the way they
handle it when they were amputated and
the way he moved around that looked
really good too i was very much i i
found that very marvelous
and this this whole
movie seemed to have this message of
just kind of
i don't know i guess it would be about
appreciation
like i like the montage at the end when
he's talking to jenny about the you know
the experiences he's had with um
[Music]
you know doing that a long marathon for
those years but the the landscapes he
saw the sights to behold
or when he was struggling at with the
with the bubblegum who was struggling
with capturing the
the the shrimp and
and looking at the the sky
even in vietnam uh uh how heavy the
weather was
and how much endurance it required
yet
that it was like the the reflecting upon
it was always about the beauty that was
there
it's something i really struggle with
personally
i it's really easy to
say look at the silver linings and
be grateful
for things it's really
really hard
it's really easy to get caught up in
circumstance
and it's something i really
really have a hard time with
and uh it was nice to just sit back with
a movie that's kind of like no
appreciate it fazel's still badass still
beats this [ __ ] will smith's everyone
who [ __ ] threatens his woman it's
great
so yeah
i liked it i'm not sure what to make of
the jenny and forrest gump relationship
honestly if there's one part of me that
at times might rub me the wrong way and
i'm not even sure how to articulate it
right now
is um
just uh
like forrest is just so forgiving and
tolerates
uh so much of the way uh he's treated
by her with so much of
like just keeps banning
she keeps abandoning him and then has a
kid that's his kid for so many years and
doesn't ever tell him about it and it's
just like it's it sometimes it can read
as
it's easy for her to take advantage of
that hit and knowing that he is going to
be a constant who is always
there for her despite however much
how despite the fact that she doesn't
seem to fully give herself over the way
how forrest does so she she can go off
and have these crazy life experiences
and sleep with all these people and
whatever like that's not the part i'm
like critical of it's more of the
there are parts of it that do feel like
yeah you kind of take advantage of the
guy a little bit though you know you
think about it he does choose to just
stick around and wait for it so you know
it's his decision ultimately
um
but that's kind of me just sort of
reaching in and
thinking of something that could that
that wasn't actually really bothering me
in the moment um but yeah as it stands
glad i finally saw it that was a really
good movie i didn't quite love it to the
heights that people maybe have built it
up to be
um and but i can imagine that the more i
think about it the more i'll really
appreciate this film
so yeah either way thank you guys for
being here i'm glad i kind of us have
some laughs and tears with you all uh
very very moving film and uh i'll talk
to you guys soon
now nothing but marvel content for the
next six days
[Music]